[Musik]
die dolomiten in südtirol sind ein
wintersportgebiet der superlative vom
grödnertal aus können besucher in
wenigen minuten per seilbahn die pisten
zwischen den berg langkofel und dem
keller massiv erreichen auf mehr als
3000 metern höhe
es sind einer der schönsten skigebiete
wenn ich das schönste skigebiet weltweit
verbunden mit sehr vielen wissen man
kann nicht nur schüler bei uns man kann
langlauf man kann rodeln man kann
eisklettern man kann wirklich alles was
mit winter zu tun hat kann man hier auf
engel haben machen
tausende pistenkilometer in allen
schwierigkeitsgraden bietet europas
größte skiregion dolomiti superski ein
verbund von insgesamt zwölf skigebieten
touristen aus aller welt haben mir spaß
im schnee
sodann die pisten sind alle miteinander
verbunden und die abfahrten lang das
macht spaß und man ist gut
immer beliebter ist eisklettern an den
vielen zu gefrorenen wasserfällen in der
region wie hier am 35 meter hohen
terrier wasser fallen bei st christina
im grödnertal auf der anderen seite
wartet das nächste highlight bergführer
hubert burda will mit zwei touristinnen
den ice besteigen das naturdenkmal ist
20 meter hoch und sehr beliebt in der
kletterszene der erfahrene eiskletterer
und bergführer zeigt worauf es ankommt
wie beim mieter ein bisschen nach links
und das sind immer noch mitte vom körper
hat
bevor die anfängerinnen loslegen
klettert hubert moroder vor und
befestigt das sicherungsseil an
speziellen am anfang die stelle so es
war einmal gekratzt bis richtig dreist
und verkünden
daran können bis zu vier personen
gesichert werden
das ist wichtig denn besonders bei den
ersten versuchen verlieren anfänger oft
den halt und fallen ins seil lockeres
eis schlägt der bergführer zur
sicherheit weg
[Musik]
nach einer viertelstunde müssen die
beiden frauen erst einmal verschnaufen
man muss den richtigen punkt suchen und
ausprobieren wo das eis dich hält
anfangs hatte ich schon angst da ich
angst hatte dass das eis bricht weil ich
ja so etwas noch nie gemacht habe
aber nein es halt und es ist ziemlich
hart
auch für geübte bergsteiger ist
eisklettern eine ganz neue erfahrung
eispickel und steigeisen muss man
kräftig ins spröde eis schlagen dabei
wird einem trotz eiseskälte schnell war
oder führt regelmäßig kleine gruppen ins
eis überall in den dolomiten
ich finde das ganz toll man hinterlässt
keine spuren
es bildet sich immer ein bisschen anders
es ist nie gleich schwierig wie das jahr
zuvor und und man kann immer andere
wasserfälle entdecken die man vielleicht
die letztes jahr nicht gefallen waren
aber das sind sie wieder gefroren ich
finde das ja
für die pause zwischendurch gibt es
zahlreiche berghütten die sind im winter
nur per seilbahn oder ski zu erreichen
und wetteifern mit kulinarischen
spezialitäten
manche gäste kommen nur deswegen hier
hoch die sophie hütte auf der cd allem
in 2400 metern höhe ist wegen ihrer
gourmetküche und ihres italienischen
flair es besonders beliebt hüttenwirt
markus prinoth serviert traditionelle
südtiroler kosten und eigene kreationen
wir versuchen regionale produkte zu
verwenden zum teil bioprodukte wir haben
aber auch eine mediterrane küche eine
internationale küche wobei wobei wir
sehr achten dass die grundprodukte nicht
zu sehr manipuliert werden um den
eigengeschmack beizubehalten
[Musik]
in den dolomiten warten noch viele
ausfälle darauf erklommen zu werden
allerdings nur nach einem längeren
aufstieg das eisklettern boomt in
südtirol ein grund viele wasserfälle
sind monatelang kletter fest ein
schnupperkurs kostet etwa 125 euro die
nötige ausrüstung kann man ausleihen ein
halber tag reicht um das klettern am
eisweiher auszuprobieren